شركة ميتا ملكة فيسبوك وواتساب
وكذلك تويتر بطرد الاف الموظفين.
ونيوزيلاندا لبحث اطلاق كوريا
الشمالية صاروخا بعيد المدى.
ظاهرة غامضة لقطعان اغنام في
الصين تسير في دائرة دون توقف
اجتماعا طارئا مع اليابان وكوريا
الجنوبية وكندا واستراليا
ساعديها. بينما يعيش العالم
اضطرابا ومن بين ركام الازمات
الرئيسي الامريكي. والبيت الابيض
يعلنها ليست هناك اي اتصالات
ولي العهد السعودي محمد بن سلمان
تايلاند لتعزيز التعاون
زيارة ولي محمد بن سلمان لسجول
فما الذي يخطط له الامير السعودي
فما الذي يحدث? قوات الامن
الايرانية قمعها ضد المحتجين
السكني بغزة. قلوبنا معكم يا اهل
غزة. عدوى تسريح الموظفين تنتقل
المملكة في تقدمها ومواجهة
مشكلاتها? الاحداث والتطورات. في
لشركة امازون باعتزامها تسريح
عشرة الاف موظف. وقد سبقت بذلك
هذا قرارا يتوقعه الجميع اعتقدنا
انه ربما يكون هناك ضوء للعدالة
وتطلق النار بعشوائية في مترو
طهران اذ ارتفع عدد القتلى لاكثر
بينهم اثنان وستون صحفيا بحسب
منظمة العفو الدولية. الامم
احتجاج رئيسية وعدد المعتقلين
ارتفع الى خمسة عشر الفا من
وثمانية وخمسين عاما كاطول حكم
بالسجن العالم. روسيا والصين
ودفع الحكومة الامريكية الى
اجراء تحقيق. هنا مصر تجد الحل
المتحدة العالم يكسر حاجز الثمان
مليارات نسمة من البشر. البزوس
الكهرباء. بول ستريت جورنال
الامريكية تفجر المفاجأة ان
الاغنام لطالما حير الصينيون
العلماء والعالم في كل شيء. وهنا
اجرى محادثة هاتفية مع امير قطر
الشيخ تميم بن حمد الثاني هنأه
غالبية قطع الطائرات المسيرة
الايرانية التي تستخدمها موسكو
الزمان. قضت محكمة تركية بسجن
الداعية التركي عدنان اوكتار
بالتأكيد قد لامست جميع ايادي
البشر بجميع الوانهم وبكل لغات
التعاون في مجالي الامن والطاقة
واكدت له ان اوكرانيا ستبقى
في الولايات المتحدة الامريكية
ولكن مرة اخرى ينتصر المال اولا.
الذي يدعو وسط الراقصات بالسجن
لمدة ثمانية الاف وستمائة
مباشرة مع كوريا الشمالية. ونحن
مستعدون للحوار معها دون شروط
يا ترى لتخرج ادارة بايدن وتطلب
الحصانة لمحمد بن سلمان في
مشروعات الطاقة المتجددة الجديدة
ستمكن مصر من الاسراع خططها
كوريا الشمالية التي اختبرت
صاروخا قادرا على بلوغ البر
العالمية تظهر ورقة المملكة
العربية السعودية وبقوة فهنا زار
ضامنة للامن الغذائي. ليعلنها
وزير الخارجية الروسي نسعى الى
اقامة نظام عالمي متعدد الاقطاب.
ومن قائمة الارباح الى قائمة
الاقتصادي. فيما اعلنت السعودية
توقيع ست وعشرين اتفاقية ومذكرة
من مائتين واربعين شخصا محطة
المترو في طهران تحولت لنقطة
تفاهم مع كوريا الجنوبية بقيمة
تسعة وعشرين مليار دولار خلال
في حلق واشنطن حيث عقدت نائبة
الرئيس الامريكي كاميليا هاريس
جنازة مهيبة. تشييع واحد وعشرين
شخصا ماتوا في حريق المبنى
القضية التي رفعتها خديجة جنكيز
عن مقتل خطيبها خاشقجي وقد تكون
واشنطن ستطلب مساعدة بكين الحليف
الابرز لبيونج يانج لكبح جماح
نانسي بيلوسي تعلن تنحيها عن
قيادة النواب الديمقراطيين في
الرئيس الشيشاني قديروف فيسخرهم
من ادراجه في قائمة المطلوبين في
مجلس النواب الامريكي وهو المنصب
الذي شغلته لقرابة عقدين من
القلق يتسلل لقلوب الامريكان
اليوم ليرد مسؤول امريكي ان
على جرائمكم ومن حروب الكر والفر
الى حروب الطاولات. هنا طاولة
الطائرات البريطانية والاوروبية.
كل هذه الحاملات ايها الناتو هنا
كوريا الشمالية اطلقت صاروخا
باليستيا عابرا للقارات كان
الحبوب لمئة وعشرين يوما لترعى
الامم المتحدة وترحب بهذا القرار
جنكيز منحت وزارة الخارجية
الامريكية حصانة لمحمد بن سلمان.
قادرا على الوصول للولايات
المتحدة الامريكية. فهل بدأ
متروك للزينسكي وبلاده لذلك عن
اي حل تتحدثون يا هؤلاء اما
هذا عالم لا يعرفه جمال ولا انا.
فهل المال حقا هو ما يساعد
لمدة اثني عشر يوما. اغنام الصين
طوفوا على طريقة الحجاج لكن
مشكلة كبيرة لبقية الغابة. عن
امريكا والصين يتحدث. طواف
هذه القضية العائق الوحيد امام
التقدم السعودي لتغرد خديجة
اردوغان التي جمعت بوتين
وزيننسكي عبر الهاتف وبمكالمة
العلاقات الصينية الكندية ليست
جيدة ليزيدها شي جين بينغ بوضعه
الصحف وهذا غير لم تكن هذه هي
الطريقة التي جرت بها المحادثة.
مرور الكرام. الصين تشعل الفتيل.
قوة الصين ما عادت تخفى على احد.
ودعت هاريس بيونج يانج الى وقف
استفزازات ليصرح البيت الابيض
لترودو في هذا الموقف المحرج.
ليخرج الرئيس الفرنسي ماكرون
الاطلسي وشمال البحر الابيض
المتوسط مع مجموعة من حاملات
مسبقة. فهل حان وقت سماع طلبات
كيم جونج? السعودية تشمر
لماذا برأيكم? لقد فعلها كيم.
صواريخ مجنون كوريا صارت اشواكا
مصرحا نحن لا نؤمن بالهيمنة
والمواجهة. نؤمن بالاستقرار
قائلا ان واشنطن ستتخذ كافة
الاجراءات لضمان امن اليابان
وكوريا الجنوبية. بينما كان
الجيش الكوري الجنوبي قد صرح ان
حليفة اخرى مما اثار القلق بين
المسؤولين والمحللين الغربيين
لتصبح المورد للطاقة والهيدروجين
لاوروبا. ومن السياسة الى
في اوكرانيا تصنعها شركات
الولايات المتحدة واوروبا ودول
توتر زادت حدة توترهما فسيبدأان
بمحاربة بعضهما. وهذه ستكون
التيار الكهربائي بسبب استهداف
موسكو للبنى التحتية لتوليد
جاستن ترودو امام الكاميرا كل
شيء ناقشناه. تم تسريبه الى
مع اردوغان بينما رئيس الاوكراني
زيلانسكي ناقشت مع اردوغان
ونؤمن بالابتكار كانهم في الغابة
ولديهم فيلان كبيران في حالة
وعلى ذات طاولة الاتصال بحث
بوتين فكرة اقامة مركز غاز تركي
العالم ستجد عبارة. هنا الرئيس
الصيني يوبخ رئيس وزراء كندا
فاصحاب العيون الضيقة غزو العالم
وبدون طلقة واحدة. وصناعتهم
خلالها بانطلاق بطولة كأس العالم
لكرة القدم بل سيمر كأس العالم
بلومبرج الامريكية نقلا عن وزير
البترول المصري طارق الملا ان
الرياضة اعلن الكريملين ان
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
لانارة اوروبا عبر كايبل اسفل
البحر المتوسط. حيث قالت وكالة
الاوكراني ان اكثر من عشرة
ملايين اوكراني محرومون من
تدمير ترسانة للمدفعية قدمتها
الدول الغربية لكييف ليخرج وزير
البيت الابيض ان الحل السياسي هو
الافضل في اوكرانيا لكن الامر
الخسائر. رئيس الوزراء المجري.
اقتصادنا يخسر عشرة مليار يورو
سنويا بسبب العقوبات الاوروبية
المفروضة على روسيا. وقال الرئيس
لعقد اجتماعات رفيعة المستوى مع
الولايات المتحدة بشأن الاستقرار
تتراجع وهو الحال ذاته لقوات
كييه. هنا اعلنت الدفاع الروسية
المنطقة. حيث كشف البنتاجون عن
خمس حاملات طائرات تعمل بالمحيط
بينما اعلن الناتو تماسكه
واستعداده للدفاع والردع في
الذي ساعد على تفادي ازمة غذاء
عالمية كانت على وشك الحدود.
اوكرانيا قائلا لستم بحاجة للبحث
عني فانا ساتي بنفسي لمعاقبتكم
الاستراتيجي اذا كانت واشنطن
مستعدة لذلك. لافتا الى انه ليس
جماعية ليعلن الرئيس التركي
بعدها نجاح تمديد اتفاق تصدير
الاوروبي مهمة مساعدة عسكرية
يعني الاتجاه نحو تصعيد الصراع.
انه سيطلق مهمة تدريبية عالية
المستوى لتدريب الالاف من الجنود
لدى موسكو ما تبحثه مع واشنطن
فيما يتعلق باوكرانيا. بينما صرح
نائب وزير الخارجية الروسي سيرجي
رياكوف يقول ان موسكو مستعدة
واشنطن لهذا الطلب؟ لكن قبل ذلك
كانت قيادة الاوكرانية قد اعلنت
بالحصول على منظومة باتريوت
الدفاعية مع تصاعد الهجمات
والحرب بين كر القوات وفرها
فتارة تتقدم روسيا وتارة اخرى
الشركات العالمية تطرد الاف
الموظفين والاحتجاجات تشتعل في
عن خمسين قتيلا وجريحا من
العسكريين الروس بقصف لقواتها في
الاوكرانية خسائر كبيرة بينما
كانت الوزارة الروسية قد اعلنت
الخارجية الاوكراني ديمترو
كوليبا ويطالب الولايات المتحدة
الصاروخية الروسية على مناطق
مختلفة في اوكرانيا. فهل تستجيب
وذلك حسب تصريحهم. وعلى ذات
الصعيد اعلن الاتحاد الاوروبي
الاوكران لترد الخارجية الروسية
وتحذر من ان اطلاق الاتحاد
سيطرتها على قرية اوبيكنوي في
الدونيتسك وتكبيد القوات
ونكرر ننصح اوكرانيا بالحل
السياسي. واردوغان ينجح بجمع
لكن هناك عائق فهل يتم تجاوزه؟
الباسوس تتنحى عن منصب وكبريات
تحرج رئيس الوزراء الكندي
وماكرون يعترف بقوة بكين ولكن
ايران. دخان الحرب يصل النيتو.
الوضع على حاله في اوكرانيا.
بطريقته الخاصة واشنطن تجمع
الحلفاء وتستنجد ببكين ضد كوريا
الشمالية وتطالب بالحوار.
والسعودية على طريق الدول العظمى
بوتين وزلنسكي في مكالمة مشتركة.
الولايات المتحدة ودول اوروبا
تدعم طيران المسير؟ اي يعقل هذا؟
ومصر تستعد لاضاءة اوروبا والصين
والسعودية كل يمضي في طريقه
لتحقيق اهدافه فمن يصل لهدف
لستم بحاجة للبحث عني فانا ساتي
اليكم. هكذا هدد الاوكران وموسكو
تدق ناقوس الخطر بهذا التصريح
والناتو يرد. والبيت الابيض نعيد